the Chinese scientist who claims to have
created the world's first genetically
edited babies revealed another woman in
his study is possibly pregnant huh John
qui made his first public comments about
the research at a summit in Hong Kong
overnight his work has drawn worldwide
condemnation he says it's now on hold
our dr. taryn Derulo's here with what
we're learning about the research that
many experts call unethical Tara good
morning good morning Gail the head of
the summit called dr. hood study
irresponsible among the concern is his
lack of transparency and questions of
whether his patients properly consented
but overnight HUD doubled down and
defended his work audience members
applauded as scientists hojin Quay took
the stage at the international gene
editing summit in Hong Kong Wednesday
but soon after he was peppered with
questions many of which he appeared
unable or unwilling to answer the
genotype may in videos posted to YouTube
this week who claimed he successfully
edited the genetic code of twin girls
while they were embryos host says he
used the gene editing tool called CRISPR
to delete a gene that makes people
vulnerable to HIV the virus that causes
AIDS the embryos were then implanted
into the mother Lulu and Lana came
crying into the world as healthy as any
other babies a few weeks ago Jennifer
Doudna is a co-inventor of the CRISPR
gene editing tool she watched her speak
I think we still need to understand the
motivation for the study and what the
process was for informed consent her
said Wednesday all the couples involved
in his study consented he directed
people to his website where he provided
an example of the consent form which
described the study as an AIDS vaccine
development project how did you recruit
these couples into your study hiv/aids
says seven couples are involved in the
study all of the father's are
hiv-positive and the mothers are HIV
negative
experts say some of the risks with this
particular gene editing is the
possibility of contracting other viruses
such as West Nile the technology is not
mature enough
Dana Carroll is a professor of
biochemistry he's worried about how his
study will affect other research
ultimately we want to make the
reproductive editing available to people
who do have devastating disease
I just hope this doesn't set us backward
how claims he paid for all his patients
medical treatments himself he's under
investigation by his University the
Chinese government and the hospital he
claims gave him ethical approval for the
trial HUS says the second potentially
pregnant woman in the study is being
monitored closely
yesterday you brought up a lot of
questions a lot of experts agree with
you today that this was not a good thing
a lot of controversy swirling around
that the technology can be good yeah
future about how this experiments the
secrecy the lack of transparency and
that he could get so far down the road
in something so magnitude and and not be
stopped somewhere that's right
thanks very much Tara the chinese
scientist who claims to have created the
world's first genetically edited babies
revealed another woman in his study is
possibly pregnant huh John qui made his
first public comments about the research
at a summit in Hong Kong overnight his
work has drawn worldwide condemnation he
says it's now on hold or dr. Tara Narula
is here with what we're learning about
the research that many experts call
unethical Tara good morning good morning
Gail the head of the summit called dr.
hood study irresponsible among the
concern is his lack of transparency and
questions of whether his patients
properly consented but overnight hood
doubled down and defended his work
audience members applauded as scientist
hood John quay took the stage at the
international gene editing summit in
Hong Kong Wednesday but soon after he
was peppered with questions many of
which he appeared unable or unwilling to
answer though genotype may quite affect
their upbringing
discusses in videos posted to YouTube
this week who claimed he successfully
edited the genetic code of twin girls
while they were embryos host says he
used the gene editing tool called CRISPR
to delete a gene that makes people
vulnerable to HIV the virus that causes
AIDS the embryos were then implanted
into the mother Lulu Alana came crying
into the world as healthy as any other
babies a few weeks ago Jennifer Doudna
is a co-inventor of the CRISPR gene
editing tool she watched her speak I
think we still need to understand the
motivation for the study and what the
process was for informed consent her
said Wednesday all the couples involved
in his study consented he directed
people to his website where he provided
an example of the consent form which
described the study as an AIDS vaccine
development project how did you recruit
these couples into your study hiv/aids
seven couples are involved in the study
all of the fathers are HIV positive and
the mothers are HIV negative experts say
some of the risks with this particular
gene editing is the possibility of
contracting other viruses such as West
Nile the technology is not mature enough
Dana Carroll is a professor of
biochemistry he's worried about how his
study will affect other research
ultimately we want to make reproductive
editing available to
we do have devastating diseases and I
just hope this doesn't set us backward
how claims he paid for all his patients
medical treatments himself he's under
investigation by his University the
Chinese government and the hospital he
claims gave him ethical approval for the
trial HUS says the second potentially
pregnant woman in the study is being
monitored closely
yesterday you brought up a lot of
questions a lot of experts agree with
you today that this was not a good thing
a lot of controversy swirling around
that the technology can be good yeah
future about how this experiments the
secrecy the lack of transparency and
that he could get so far down the road
in something so magnitude and and not be
stopped somewhere that's right thanks
very much Tara